your individual life vest  is located in a pouch beneath your seat  should its use become necessary  [Music]  bring the straps around your waist pull  on the loose straps  [Music]  until the vest fits snugly as we are now  demonstrating  thank you for your attention  we will be airborne shortly  we are torn apart by events i like to be  submissive  do you know what that means  [Music]  put back together differently by others  why japan  sometimes being alone isn't about other  people alone  is about people be careful then how do  you know that i'm not a bad man  [Music]  i don't  how do you know difficult to make you  happy  i think i'm destined to go nuts nobody  uses their public face in the express  sometimes the mask is prettier than the  thing  behind it i tell myself there is no  happy ending  all the pieces do not fit together  perfectly  but somehow everything is beautiful  you